♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
BETO O'ROURKE HAS CHANGED, HE IS
NOT NOT THOUGH BOYISH CAREFREE
ROAD TRIP WITH THE WHEAT HOOK UP
THAT YOU MIGHT REMEMBER FROM
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
THAT TO BETO IS GONE, MAYBE
FOREVER.
AT THE NEW BETO IS FAR MORE
SERIOUS.
EVEN ANGRY.
WHAT IS THE NEW BETO MAD ABOUT?
CLIMATE CHANGE, OBVIOUSLY.
BORDER WALLS, AND BIGOTRY AND
UPTIGHT OLD PEOPLE THAT DO NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT SKATEBOARDING IS
NOT A CRIME.
ALSO THAT BUZZ KILL PETE
BUTTIGIEG WHO STOLE HIS SPOT IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL RANKING, THAT
WAS ANNOYING AS HELL.
BUT MOSTLY WHAT BETO IS MAD AT
HIS BETO.
HE HAS HAD SOME TIME SINCE BEING
UNEMPLOYED.
HE CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
ACTUALLY HE IS A PRETTY MEDIOCRE
PERSON.
NOT A GOOD GUY AT ALL.
PRETTY MUCH IN AND THOUGHTFUL
HUMAN BEING.
MOST PEOPLE WOULD KEEP THAT
KNOWLEDGE TO THEMSELVES.
NOT BETO, HE WENT ON "THE VIEW"
TODAY TO TELL EVERYONE.
>> YOU AND ANSWER CAMPAIGN AND
SAID THAT YOU WERE "BORN TO BE
IN IT."
HE WENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON A
ROAD TRIP AFTER YOU LOST YOUR
ELECTION AND YOU SAID "SOMETIMES
HELPED RAISE YOUR KIDS."
THESE ARE THINGS THAT A FEMALE
CANDIDATE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GET AWAY WITH.
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN GET AWAY
WITH MORE BECAUSE YOU ARE A MAN?
AND DO YOU HAVE ANY REGRETS OF
LAUNCHING ON THE COVER OF
"VANITY FAIR"?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, THEY ARE
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN PRIVILEGED
TO DO IN MY LIFE THAT OTHERS
CANNOT.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE RIGHT SAID
BETO.
MALE PRIVILEGE IS REAL.
I SHOULD KNOW, ALL OF THE COOL
FUN THINGS I DID IN MY LIFE, I
HAVE ONLY DONE BECAUSE I AM A
MAN.
AND I FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT.
SO BAD THAT I'VE HAD MEDIA
CONSULTANTS WRITE MORAL
CULPABILITY THAT I WILL READ TO
YOU WITH FEIGNED SINCERITY
HOPING THAT IT IS ATONEMENT FOR
MY SINS.
HERE WE GO.
SPEAK OF THE SYSTEMATIC
FOUNDATIONAL DISCRIMINATION THAT
WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY AND IN
EVERY ASPECT OF LIFE IS
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED IN MY LIFETIME.
AND I HAVE HAD ADVANTAGES THAT
OTHER CANNOT ENJOY.
>> Tucker: THAT CLEARS THAT
UP.
IN CASE YOU THOUGHT BETO MIGHT
BE SUFFERING FROM SYSTEMATIC
FOUNDATIONAL DISCRIMINATION IN
EVERY ASPECT OF HIS LIFE, NOW
YOU KNOW THE TRUTH, HE IS NOT.
AND HE IS DEEPLY ASHAMED OF
THAT.
BECAUSE IT IS MORALLY SUPERIOR
TO BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AS
THE RICH AND PAMPERED LADIES OF
"LOVE YOU" WHO ARE SOMEWHAT
VICTIMS WILL TELL YOU.
BUT PEOPLE DO NOT HATE HIM FOR
WHO HE IS, THAT IS THE DOWNSIDE
OF PRIVILEGE, PEOPLE LIKE YOU
TOO MUCH.
ALL BETO CAN DO IS TRY HARDER TO
BE DESPISED AS MUCH AS HE
DESPISES HIMSELF.
WHICH HE HAS PLEDGED TO DO.
>> I HAVE MY WORK CUT OUT FOR ME
TO BE A BETTER PERSON AND ENSURE
THAT I AM MORE MINDFUL TO THE
EXPERIENCES THAT OTHERS HAVE HAD
DIFFERENT THAN THE EXPERIENCES
THAT I HAVE HAD.
>> ARE THOSE MISTAKES?
ARE THOSE MISTAKES BEING ON THE
COVER OF "VANITY FAIR"?
IT LOOKS ELITIST?
>> YES, IT REINFORCES THAT
PERCEPTION OF PRIVILEGE, AND
THAT HEADLINE THAT SAID I WAS
BORN TO BE IN THIS IN THE
ARTICLE IS ATTEMPTING TO SAY
THAT I FELT THAT MY CALLING WAS
IN PUBLIC SERVICE, NO ONE IS
BORN TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
LEAST OF ALL ME.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FOURTH TIME
THING?
YOU GOT SOME FLACK FOR THAT ONE.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY AND I DESERVE
IT.
>> Tucker: THE LADY WHO MAKES
WILLIAMS TALKING ABOUT HERSELF
ON A TV SHOW DISAPPROVES OF BETO
APPEARING ON A MAGAZINE COVER BC
APPEARING ON A MAGAZINE COVER BU
APPEARING ON A MAGAZINE COVER BE
APPEARING ON A MAGAZINE COVER BI
APPEARING ON A MAGAZINE COVER BT
IS ELITIST.
AND BETO AGREES WITH HER.
OF COURSE HE DOES.
THERE IS NO CRITICISM OF BETO
THAT BETO DOES NOT AGREE WITH.
BACK IN MARCH HE APOLOGIZED
PROFUSELY FOR SAYING THAT HIS
WIFE HAVE RAISED THEIR THREE
KIDS.
DID YOU KNOW HOW PATRIARCHAL
THAT SOUNDS.
BETO DOES?
AND HE IS TRULY SINCERELY SORRY
HE SAID IT.
>> NOT ONLY WILL I NOT SAY
THAT --
[LAUGHTER]
>> BUT I WILL BE MUCH MORE
THOUGHTFUL GOING FORWARD IN WAYS
THAT I TALK ABOUT OUR MARRIAGE,
AND ALSO THE WAY THAT I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUTH OF THE
CRITICISM THAT I HAVE ENJOYED
WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> Tucker: I HAVE ENJOYED
THERE YOU GO.
HE ACKNOWLEDGED IT.
THANK YOU, MR. O'ROURKE FOR YOUR
CANDOR, BUT THE REAL QUESTION IS
HOW MUCH DID YOU ENJOY WHITE
PRIVILEGE?
WE WILL GET TO THOSE DETAILS IN
OUR NEXT ROUND OF QUESTIONING.
IN THE MEANTIME WE DON'T WANT TO
GIVE YOU THE IMPRESSION THAT
BETO IS THE ONLY ONE GROVELING
HERE.
FAR FROM IT.
THEY ALL ARE.
FOR DEMOCRATS IN 2019 TO RUN IS
TO GROVEL.
HERE IS MAYOR PETE OF SOUTH BEND
REMEMBERING WHAT SADNESS AND
FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN HE SUGGESTED
THAT ALL HUMAN LIFE HAD VALUE.
HOW COULD HE HAVE BEEN SO STUPID
AND CRUEL?
>> 2016 YOU SAID THAT ALL LIVES
MATTER WHEN YOU SPOKE ABOUT TWO
POLICE CONTROVERSIES THAT WERE
HAPPENING IN SOUTH BEND.
WAS THAT A MISTAKE?
>> WHAT I DID NOT UNDERSTAND AT
THAT TIME WAS THAT THAT PHRASE
JUST EARLY INTO THE MID-2015 WAS
COMING TO BE VIEWED AS SORT OF A
COUNTER SLOGAN TO BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
AND SO THE STATEMENT THAT SEEMS
VERY ANODYNE AND SOMETHING THAT
NOBODY COULD BE AGAINST ACTUALLY
WOUND UP BEING USED TO DEVALUE
WHAT TO THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT WAS TELLING US.
SINCE LEARNING ABOUT HOW THAT
PHRASE IS BEING USED TO PUSH
THAT ON THAT ACTIVIST, I HAVE
STOPPED USING IT IN THAT
CONTEXT.
>> Tucker: HOW COULD I HAVE
BEEN SO STUPID?
AND HERE IS KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
OF NEW YORK CALLING IN ON
TILLERY ON HER OWN POSITION
AFTER AN NBC RESEARCHER
DISCOVERED THAT SHE HAD ONE SUPO
DISCOVERED THAT SHE HAD ONE SUPT
DISCOVERED THAT SHE HAD ONE SUPD
BORDER.
SERIOUSLY.
>> YOU SAID THAT YOU WERE
EMBARRASSED ABOUT YOUR PREVIOUS
POSITION ON IMMIGRATION, TELL ME
ABOUT THAT.
>> IT WAS NOT DRIVEN FROM MY
HEART.
I WAS CALLOUSED OF THE SUFFERING
OF FAMILIES WHO WANT TO BE WITH
THEIR LOVED ONES.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE REUNITED
WITH THEIR FAMILY IS, AND I
RECOGNIZE AS WE ALL DO THAT
IMMIGRATION AND DIVERSITY IS OUR
STRENGTH AS A COUNTRY.
I REALLY REGRETTED THAT I DID
NOT LOOK BEYOND MY DISTRICT AND
TALK ABOUT WHY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
UNITED STATES STORY.
>> Tucker: I WAS CALLOUSED.
I WAS HEARTLESS.
DON'T HATE ME.
I HATE MYSELF ENOUGH.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR SHARING,
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR SELF-ESTEEM
ISSUES.
JOE BIDEN IS A GOOD QUARTER
CENTURY OLDER THAN
SENATOR GILLIBRAND WHO HERSELF
IS OLDER THAN A LOT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES.
HE WOULD THINK THAT JOE BIDEN
WILL BE OLD ENOUGH TO EARN THE
RIGHT NOT TO SAY THAT HE IS
SORRY.
BUT THINK AGAIN.
AGE IT SELF IS SOMETHING TO
APOLOGIZE FOR.
AND JOE BIDEN DID.
HE GREW UP IN A TIME BEFORE
HUMAN WAR WAS RECLASSIFIED AS A
HUMAN ACT.
AND HE IS VERY, VERY SORRY FOR
THAT.
>> SOCIAL WARS HAVE BEGAN TO
CHANGE AND HAVE SHIFTED.
AND THE BOUNDARY OF PROTECTING
PERSONAL SPACE HAS BEEN RESET.
AND I GET IT.
I GET IT.
I HEAR WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
I WILL BE MORE MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF PEOPLE'S PERSONAL
SPACE.
>> Tucker: WE COULD GO ON WITH
THE ORGIE OF APOLOGY, KAMALA
HARRIS APOLOGIZING.
BERNIE SANDERS APOLOGIZING FOR
HOW WOMEN WERE TREATED ON HIS
LAST CAMPAIGN.
AMY KLOBUCHAR APOLOGIZING FOR
ONE SWIMMING PIZZA IN SCHOOL
CAFETERIAS.
IN A WORLD ABOUT FORGIVENESS
THIS IS A CYCLE THAT CONTINUES,
NO CYCLE IS ENOUGH PREY TO THE
LEFT IS A ROLLING INQUISITION
WITH A BOTTOMLESS APPETITE FOR
RITUAL PUNISHMENT AND --
TELL US YOU HAVE BEEN NAUGHTY,
THANK YOU, SIR.
CAN I HAVE ANOTHER.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SICK.
THEY HAVE NO DIGNITY OR
SELF-RESPECT.
THERE IS NOTHING THEY WILL NOT